السعوديه تفتح ابوابها لمشجعك كاس العالم
من حاملي بطاقات هيا وهيا معي
حاملوا بطاقات هيا وبطاقات هيا معي ثلاثه
زائد واحد التي تتيح اصطحاب مرافقين ثلاثه
يستطيعوا اصحابها اصدار تاشيره سياحيه
تمكنه من الاستمتاع بالتجارب والواجهات
السياحيه قبل انطلاق المونديال بعشره ايام
ايضا هذه البطاقات يستطيعون من خلالها
البقاء في السعوديه لمده ستين يوما حملوا
هذه البطاقات يحصلون على تاشيرتي دخول
متعدده الى السعوديه مجانا دون الحاجه
لدفع اي مبلغ مالي
[تصفيق]
على فكره جيده جدا
اولا سبورت كاس العالم وثانيا دعم للاخوه
العرب انهم يتعرفوا على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وممكن من خلال البطاقه دي ممكن
اكثر من مره فرصه رائعه تفتيح لانه كمان
يتمتع بموسم الرياض
وياخذ فكره جيده على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
واللي يكون يعني ذاهب قطر
للمشاركه في كاس العالم كمتفرج ولا كم
مشجع يستطيع الدخول السعوديه
واخذ قصه من السياحه المتوفره هنا يعني
شيء جميل
هلا فيك الحب اكثر من 2300 رحله جويه
ستوفرها خمسه مطارات دوليه وهي مطارات
الرياض وجده والدمام بالاضافه الى المدينه
المنوره والقصيم للراغبين بحضور مباريات
كاس العالم هذه الرحلات ستوفر اكثر من
636,000 سعره مقعديه مطار الملك خالد في
الرياض الذي نحن فيه الان افتتح صالتين
دوليتين ثلاثه واربعه بعد تجديدهما
بالكامل لاستقبال مشجعي كاس العالم
والرحلات التردديه المتوجهه الى قطر ايضا
المطارات الاخرى شهد التجهيزات خاصه
لاستقبال مشجعين كاس العالم والزوار
القادمين الى السعودي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هؤلاء السياح لن يكونوا في حيره من امرهم
عندما تضع اقدامهم ارض السعوديه منصه
حاضرين ستوفر لهم المعلومات حول الوجهات
السياحيه والفاعليه المتنوعه ايضا هذه
المنصه تقدم الدعم في حاله وجود اي
استفسارات او حاله طارئه بالنسبه للمشجعين
فقط عليهم زياره موقع هيف فور يو دوت اس
اي المركز الوطني للعمليات الامنيه تسعه
واحد واحد هو الاخر يقدم الدعم للزوار
ومشجعي كاس العالم على مدار الساعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مدينه الرياض
العربيه
[تصفيق]